target toi élargi toi un petit peu voilà
douze morts attends attends attends un
serpent ben c'est mon cerveau sur mer
puisée au dessus d'un lit en tant
qu'avocat de chapelure rebond du dollar
était à larry tu sais pas si ce n'est
peut-être pas assez large pas grave ils
sont comme ça on va refaire un plan du
retard doit faire à un joli top singles
à toi tu vas tu vas la télé agir verte à
gauche de rentrées d'argent et tu verras
tout le pote soit le réservé hier avec
le bleu des trucs que tu comptes la plus
verte à gauche sais pas si tu comprends
ce que je veux dire
énergie cités des rumeurs ragots suivra
voilà comme ça voilà voilà exactement sa
voix la pure race est super en mode du
vert
la réserve a pas encore de la réserve tu
veux en pack c'est un peu ouais et
l'argent car ça c'est joli conte davidas
bien on s'est superposé des animaux de
danse et vous allez voir c'est ben et
puis quand pas offert un filet c'est bon
pas tu publies au fils ismaïl plan de
tournée peut dire un petit mot plan
bon quand il regarde par la fenêtre
regarde pas tant il n'entend pas
dévoiler toute l'échelle ines un rang
bas on va faire on va filmer ça ok très
joli 100 km dernier wall street
voilà ok c'est un appareil twitter joly
a dit hervé 15 à côté pour proposer ou
encore mieux il a un super plein
d'animaux là bas au bout voilà tu fais
un peu des plans observa la jolie
c'était un petit village avec eux
et drake et plein de l'ibo et très très
beau là bas
je ressors de satan qui sort le danton
truc
voilà on va aller en voir un qui est
très très beau là bas que je dis bof bof
ok tout moment par le grand la voix des
citoyens en losange et voila voila je
suis là voilà voilà
on le bien celui-là voilà enfin pourra
sortir de l'oubli pas de sortir du champ
quand europe tu dois filmer et c'est
vrai qu'il a maintenant besoin voilà
c'est ça va nous aider à le découvrir
avec ses tresses et tranquillement
devant l'arbre pour paris vraiment sofia
du barbelé du plastique les moins
traditionnel de l'autre on aura été bien
toi c'est de prendre celui là et puis de
deux taylor jir vers la gauche est de
couvrir tout le village
tu vas avoir avec comment la paix tout à
l'heure ce nordiste all i want it de la
très touchante et énergie verte à gauche
tu vas vers le village est complet
depuis bâle ou pas non c'est bien sûr
parce que ce n'est plus bas n'aura plus
de profondeur préfecture celle fictive
et bien comme ça oui le tour est valide
à l'oeil la rumeur reprend bourgeoisie
bras gauche carrément là on est trop
vertical en wallonie la longueur le voir
toi là tu peux faire c'est un passionné
plus tard ce sera mieux de les animer
vois pas tous les bars et dans tous les
sens dois je le dire ça ne pète pas au
dessus du village là où on est on dit ce
qu'on va un peu plus loin derrière nous
et on est un peu plus bas et on aura le
temps aller les animaux en avant-plan et
derrière le village soit la mangrove 2
du fleuve les petits villages qui somme
toute nous la couette et maison toute
évidence maisons qui sont cools ils les
voient ces maisons là quelques animaux
tout ça dans l'art entre la torre voilà
rentrer là dedans il va un peu à tout ça
todd hockey dans l'attenté peut
découvrir ton village derrière si tu le
vois là on va passer en latéral trouve
le temps n'est pas le cas de besoin des
villages et facili juste grillagée
derrière et du monde derrière telle
adversité quand tu montes un village
derrière quand je te dis de mettre en
bas c'est vraiment l'âge de 2 ans pareil
ne mettront pas le truc le village là il
va se passer non c'est bon mais on va
leur faire un parce qu' on est loin du
compte et d'énergie un peu plus tôt déjà
non mais surtout c'est pas mal c'est pas
mal c'est pas mal ça c'est joli ça voilà
voilà
ce match combien c'est vachement bien ça
le seul truc tanguy quoi tu fasses c'est
très bien voilà c'est très bien ça alors
c'est pas mal ça
5il en face il ya la laitue là qu'on va
découvrir le village et dans le vide
alors qu on peut pas les grosses village
c'est impossible
le patin des besoins ponctuels qui
n'écoute pas le seul à le poser au kenya
droite bien c'est tout commence comme ça
maintenant qu'il faudrait commencer
énergie pouvoir levier choix voilà va
commencer la livraison d'armes
tiens pas quelque chose au point que on
va être close voilà on à sebala ouais ok
tensions perdurent en voir sa voix de
jean renvoi de 101 e à droite en bas
est ce donc un voile à sa table comme ça
au cours à tour par deux bien bien bien
bien comme ça et récit commence à
élargir ou tout doux l'énergie village à
rentrer là commencent à rentrer y
compris des allergies re ok ok contrit
dur
voilà va récupérer l'eau je pense pas
parce que c'est large ça reste comme ça
voilà en récupère la rivière eux vers le
printemps ce contenu top top ne vont pas
plus à risque comme ça alors voilà on
s'enroule avec l'hélico en rhône alpes
le hockey bon on aurait eu assez
longtemps je pensais pas je pense qu'on
n'est pas par tcc raid sur du très long
le voir on continue à tourner comme ça
parce que 3 contre eux et ça va venir
vite car d autres devant l'ars gheriani
moi je leur dirai plus quand on veut
dans le plus pur intense du roy gérard
giret et serait toujours n'a toujous
carte bleue attention voici julien et
qu'ils apprécient un peu plus si avec
cary si bien gardés j'élargis commence à
mesure comment s'élargir allergies et
derrière voilà dans cet axe là derrière
un village derrière juste en cet axe la
pesc bien en bas du truc dans cet axe-là
hâtivement je fais descendre un peu
d'hélicoptères ce qui fait que ça
permettra d'avoir viré un peu de chance
mais bon tu mens tu rentres tu mon petit
vent tu rentres tu mens tu vas jusqu'au
bout
tu as jusqu'à voir le ciel asie
tu descends le toulois bien le boulot
pop voilà est bien ou pas à ça wen s'est
repris avec un fougueux le départ n est
pas ce qu elle se fâche c'est qu'il ya
beaucoup de il ya une grande longueur
avec rien avant d'arriver se voit pas au
revoir il ya vraiment s'est longtemps
avec le haïku sable quoi ça c'est pas
mal hein voilà tout quitté vers
l'ontario le quitter en clôturant le
client recrute en kit comme sa voisine
qui est on va vers le bas tout anormal
excellent airs et un peu pour descente
vers le concret dit que c'est bon
4 kw à cayenne on vient de la rue à tous
voilà à tour du maire de kiev pour
touristes tout ça pour quoi